carlson's nightmare
uh yet another turkish player um
good to see um
i think after this one i'll try a couple
of um
a couple of three minute games just uh
want to get um
i want to get a bit warmed up
knight f6 this is a move that i often
see in simultaneous this place and
no that's not meant as a compliment
unfortunately
because the move is just not very good
it's a bit
similar to the grenfell but you don't
get that
weakness on c3 after after e4
and this basically means that
i will get a pretty free free reign in
the center
after knight c6 then d5
is also coming which gives me even more
tempo in the center
uh and i think i'll just continue in the
same vein
try and attack more a4 and then if
a5 as was probably more or less forced
then black will have some
some issues with um with the knight and
b6
and um those squares being a bit
weak over there i think now through
ed5 i'll take on b6
try and keep the initiative going and
then bishop e5
this obviously cannot be met by knight
c6 that's the ed5 with the
with a lethal pin so bishop d7 is forest
now after queen d5 i really
have a pretty fearsome lead in
development
knight c6 and uh here i think i'll i'll
i'll just
try and uh and
um add as much fuel to the fire
as soon as possible
it's queen e7 now looks like almost the
only move
knight e5 queen e5 fish p7 is not
possible because of
rook d1 with a with a little pin and if
queen e7 instead i have bishop d7
which means that the king will have to
go for
for a bit of a walk which
works are generally healthy for you but
i don't think this one is
rookie one jack and now i believe
king c8 is absolutely forced king eight
queen b5 will be made to the next move i
have queen cs6
apart from looking very ugly at the very
least i have queen b5
king c7 the knight d5
winning immediately so he quite
correctly goes
king c8 was the only way to continue the
game
and now yeah for queen
b5 i think queen e6 is the best way to
fight
i have to say it's not it's not quite
over
queen is sex followed by bishop c5 he
concerned me
you can certainly put off a lot of your
system
more than on
more than i'm 100 comfortable with
like i thought i thought this would be
close to over
but maybe i actually rushed it
i was just thinking development
advantage and
all of um
all of the positional trumps that i have
but the bishman c5 is really really good
this means that the advantage that i
have is
somewhat limited so now i'm trying to
reroute my thesis a bit k8 now
trying to escape with the king i'm going
to go queen d3
with a few ideas one which is to go
green to g3
with a knife to check but the other one
just as important is to go
knight to b5 once the king comes to a7
to force it back
and this means that he probably cannot
survive for very long after all
knight is going to b5 and the rook to d1
creating a nasty threat
rook to the eight as well
so maybe there is some some
some sense there is some logic in the
world
after all okay i'll go rook d1 first
maybe just to make sure rook
d8 doesn't happen and if team v8 knight
b5
looks very very strong
yeah my opponent has fought really well
after an initial bad opening but i think
there's just nothing here
too many um too many weakness like if
you put the black king on g8 on the rook
on f8
then he's only a little bit worse
but yeah but the king
as as it is is just hopeless
rook c8 and now we're gonna see a very
quick
mate i believe quincy a7 is probably the
way only way to
prolong it to between obviously no one's
gonna
gonna want to do that game now